right now hospital capacity remains at a
secure level in southern nevada
with that said health officials are
urging nevadans to not relax on their
health guidelines
as kate houston reports hospitals are
now trying to avoid a second surge
the ceo at umc says while we're not
currently in a surge we're definitely
headed that way based off of current
positivity rates
now hospitals in southern nevada are
asking community members to step
up their safety guidelines to avoid a
rollback on restrictions
right now 82 percent of hospital beds in
southern nevada
are occupied of those nearly 15 percent
are confirmed covet patients intensive
care units are 66 percent occupied
with nearly 35 percent covet positive
although hospital capacity in southern
nevada is stable
umc ceo mason van howling says the way
the high positivity rate is trending
is serious we're not at our peaks that
where we saw
in april and then july at the july 4th
weekend
so we're just trying to avoid that and
be get really ahead of this
so but we're in good shape but that can
quickly change
van howling says much of the surge is
because of non-compliance with people
not wearing masks properly and not
washing their hands or sanitizing
frequently he thinks getting the
positivity rate under control in two
weeks
will only be attainable if everyone does
their part
it's going to be a huge task but we need
everybody to participate so
that's all we're asking and let's just
flatten this right now let's get ahead
of it
so we don't have to roll back our
economy in las vegas we just cannot
afford to do that van gaaling adds that
northern nevada is experiencing a higher
hospitalization rate than southern
nevada
the hospitals down here are capable of
assisting with covid 19 patients
if needed kate houston 8 news now
umc plans to open a new testing site
soon it'll be a drive-through
site located over at texas station